[Music]
hey now party people welcome to the
australian commentaries for eternal is
it the internals or eternals they are
just eternals just eternals um
this will be a fun one i guess uh we're
gonna talk about our thoughts behind the
scenes thoughts on the honest trailer uh
show you some cut jokes and stuff like
that uh deleted scenes then we get to
talk to you the audience so keep those
questions and comments coming in the
chat and we will respond to them at the
end of the show before teasing you with
next week's honest trailer it's going to
be a grunty one um so
eternals uh i'm trying to remember
eternals uh because there was a lot of
movie there um we were also trying to
challenging each other to remember all
ten eternals before we start filming and
lon says he can do it i think danielle
and i would struggle
so i think he's happy bashful
uh a film that uh look i i respect the
effort i like that they tried something
different and it definitely was
different than the usual marvel stuff we
get
not really my cup of tea um i thought it
was anytime something opens with a big
crawl of proper nouns um and definitions
of terms
i'm like uh-oh
wait a minute how did palpatine return
again eternals i don't understand this
at all but it was it was different from
that it'd be like if if it was like a
like wikipedia if it was no disrespect
to our parent company fandom we love you
but if it was like uh midichlorians are
the things that make the jedis work the
jedi are an order of monks the sith are
this like it was it was a lot of terms
that um wasn't the most cinematic way to
start but i thought there was there was
cool imagery
uh i thought the fight scenes were
actually pretty pretty well done
and there were some pops of character
that i liked but man pacing wise i feel
like this movie felt all of its two and
a half plus hours and it was kind of a
lot of hurry up and then a lot of weight
and then a lot of hurry it was just
unevenly paced for me but what did you
guys think overall about the eternals or
eternals eternals um thank you lon um
yeah like it's uh i agree with most of
what you're saying i it was too it's too
much movie for
you know you've got to introduce all
these people you've got to introduce
this huge new concept of the being the
celestials and you have to stop a
deviant they eat a planet i'm still i
watched it a bunch of times because we
do that for the trailers and i'm still
kind of like i think i got what the plot
with this was um
but mostly it's um
it reminded me a lot of cats in that way
where it was like oh it's a newer turtle
oh cool what does this what what is this
eternal song going to be about you
should have done the whole trailer like
that where they come in and do cat style
songs introducing themselves they really
should have mr kingo the movie star
next time next time next time but yeah
so it again i just think it was um it's
very pretty it's super gorgeous it looks
amazing but i was definitely finding
myself getting lost um
in not in a way where it's like i don't
get it but in a way where um i was
struggling to see the importance or
urgency in anything that was happening
until like the very end
yeah i mean when the stakes are it's
such an abstract
thing at stake i know it's like the well
it's almost too big to really connect
with because it's the face of all of
human humanity versus the fate of
theoretical unborn planetary races of
beings and it's like you got to bring it
down to a level
that like i can connect with because
it's just it's like literally i mean
this is kind of the criticism that
people either love or hate about dc's
they're so godlike and removed from your
everyday human
cares and tribulations it's like
this is not like spider-man where he's
saving the world at one point and then
he's gotta go to school he's gotta oh
he's gonna kiss mary jane and stuff like
that like we were missing that side of
the equation which is what we're just
used to with marvel which is i guess why
people didn't like this one as much uh
what do you think one yeah i like this a
lot actually and i like the different
like i i i agree with what you're saying
that it doesn't it doesn't feel like the
other
mcu movies it doesn't follow the
formulas closely and there have been
other ones i liked recently like i like
chongqi a lot and that follows the
formula pretty closely and this one is a
real purposeful in some ways i felt like
break from that it really does set up a
different part of the world and then it
is it's kind of this morality like it
centers on this moral conundrum this
sort of trolley problem kind of
variation that they're trapped in
and uh i thought that was that was an
interesting way to play it out like i'm
glad not every marvel movie is like this
because i agree that would be a bit much
it would start to feel like irrelevant
and disconnected from like our daily
kind of like what we like about
superhero movies maybe but as a
here's a different way of approaching
these marvel movies here's a new crop of
characters and here's like a
like a genuinely tough question and i
really admired how the movie doesn't do
the usual thing and this is not just
marvel it doesn't give you an easy way
out like normally we've talked about
this in other marvel stuff before where
the bad guy makes a lot of sense like
you'll get a killmonger and you're like
i agree with the bad guy but then
they'll do one horrible thing to be like
they're evil we can't let them win
they're gonna kill that van full of
civilians or he's gonna start a bunch of
wars and and it like forces your hand
like okay he's the bad guy now and this
never gives you an out the the bad guys
or the people who join the opposing
antagonistic team
they're making a lot of good points and
then you get kingdom as well who's sort
of like i'm not gonna join the heroes or
the antagonists i'm gonna leave before
the climax even happens and i thought
that was after 20 plus marble movies i
thought that was really interesting
it was refreshing to have a completely
passive hero
well you see let's just see how it
shakes out i mean after several dozen of
these like i'm ready for people to just
make like weird decisions and try
something different and like let's take
a different look at these kinds of
stories now that we've been told them so
many times we're really starting to
explore their their kind of nuances uh
the one thing i think didn't work you
had highlighted the action scenes i felt
like i loved chloe jowe's decision to
shoot on natural locations and it really
does also help set the movie
aesthetically apart from the other
marvel movies but i felt like it kind of
clashes with the like
weird rope dog monsters and light laser
battles like all that stuff i think it
looks worse because it's not
in a green screen in room and i mean the
design of the
deviants
it's not gonna be uh in the hall of good
marvel villains i think that they're
i've used i've used rope dogs i think
you came with bundled up cables and
wires which is also very apt yeah
yeah i think i might have liked this
film more if they said it entirely in
past historical eras i think that might
have been more interesting even though
that puts it in prequel territory but
you avoid the whole like why didn't they
if they're here to increase the human
population why didn't they stop thanos
like really they didn't make an
exception for that and like if they kind
of embraced that okay these characters
are the roots of humanities like myth
creation myths and like great leaps
forward and techno technological
development and like never got to the
point where they're like
i don't know uh going to a bar and like
sprite's trying to pick up dudes
like walking around london and
everybody's just shrugging their
shoulders at the emergence of a rope dog
but i guess in the mcu rope dogs or
something
just that weird habit i didn't think
that became a big deal until the very
end like the rope dogs should be like
all right it's like thor stuff whatever
we've seen that before but uh the very
end at spoiler alert
like a the head of a massive
planet-sized god appears over london
which is like ew and like snatches a
lady up and people are like you know
they're a little freaky oh whoa hey
they're freaked out in the way like if
there was just like a hurricane warning
you'd be like oh we should get out of
here but not like a god just appeared
freaked out like that would be another
level of i mean that you would like fall
to your knees and like scream like like
raining of garments and gnashing of
teeth and like yeah just like running
and looting and like nothing matters god
is here and doesn't care it's literally
a god like i'm here like it's the end
it's the end times for sure that's what
we're doing i feel like that would that
would do it for me um sanity-wise
you come back like 10 seconds later and
everybody's like almost calmed down
there's like a car alarm going up in the
distance like
god was just here
hey sorry i'm late to work
you know how that is well you know i
just missed five uh years of my life it
literally in a void and then came back
like they take it all in stride at this
point they do really they really do take
it all in stride kid harrington at the
beginning too hasn't like he just found
out his girlfriend is like a god and his
fighting monsters and he's like
so but you used to date that guy like
he's really more hung up on the
relationship stuff
yeah just another day in the life of the
mcu um all right let's watch you on his
trailer see what else we picked out
[Music]
marvel has taken you out to the edge of
the universe down to the scale of an
atom and across the boundaries of time
now prepare to visit a new setting
beyond the farthest reaches of a nerd's
imagination
outside i'm scared can we go back to a
green screen please
ah that's better
eternals
witness the mcu's grandest experiment
yet about mythic creatures who steer the
course of human history from the
director of that quasi documentary about
a van lady who poops in a bucket
good movie you may have heard of it
also the writer great film as chloe xiao
brings jack kirby's most psychedelic r
to the screen and soothing grays and
beiges in this long meditation on
whether our hero should let humanity die
or spit in the face of an uncaring god
are we sure this isn't a dc movie that's
superman
that's superman
remember
how i guess this could we could talk
about this later but like
do you think that this is something
like an ant-man movie or whatever where
where marvel's like
you know they're hoping that it's a
success but they're not like banking on
the future phases and installments
really building off of it or do you
think this was supposed to be like the
linchpin of this new
mcu phase and they're like uh oh you
kind of screwed the pooch here
or or do you think this can because it
kind of felt like a one-off movie you
really didn't need to know anything
about marvel to enjoy it but will we
need to remember fast dos going forward
i don't know
i think the it's pretty clear the main
mcu storyline is multiverse everything
right now and this is more sort of like
a
i think this is more like yeah like an
ant-man or a guardians like let's see if
we can get people interested in this
property that does not have a huge
iconic sort of background for most
people and uh
yeah i i mean i think they're they're
obviously things they're planning on
like i mean obviously we're gonna get
harry styles yeah they obviously work
right that stuff and then black knight i
think it's pretty clear they want kit
harington's guy to become his own thing
and they're teasing uh you know him
gonna
team up with blade at some point
uh but yeah i don't i don't think this
is like the hub of phase four in the way
that like dr strange or spiderman
it's just annoying because now we're
gonna have the
the what where are the avengers
questions but it'll be like where are
the eternals uh yeah where's fastos
i honestly don't know if we're gonna get
a lot of where's fastos
a little skeptical
i say
all right let's keep going remember when
comic book films were about characters
you've heard of neither do i
now after a tldr opening crawl meet the
eternals 10 heroes as hot as they are
sad thrill at the revelation that
they're actually robots designed by an
alien god to fight creatures who look
like your unsorted cable drawer who
themselves were designed to eat the
dinosaurs until things got out of hand
you know what just forget it it's dumb
just meet the eternals surprise no we're
gonna we're gonna work through this
so the celestials they're
effing planets and and making babies
right um
and the way they do that they they make
stars
which allow for life to blossom
throughout the universe but in order to
make a star you need a celestial and the
only way to make a celestial is using a
whole populated world as an egg it's an
egg yeah but
so they create the deviants to eat the
tigers or whatever that are eating
this is where it gets a little hanky but
yes apparently as worlds populate
under these powerful suns that they're
creating they're you know native hostile
predatory species arise but they aren't
the intelligent species they need to
incubate them it's a little bit like the
matrix like the machines in the matrix
need humans as batteries and sort of
like
with the deviants they did it
biologically and they evolved and that
was their mistake so now they need to
make like the roomba like clean up
vacuums uh which and you can like rinse
and repeat with their wipe their
memories and have them like their
memories
when you know you're a sick side mega
god you could just be like i'm going to
kill all the tigers or deviants bam
here's i got i got a few i i do have a
few core questions one is if we presume
that celestials are themselves eternal
why do they need to make more of them
like they're they're just there are
celestials like you need to keep making
more celestial why like just make a star
and then move on to the next star what
do you what do you do i mean there's
like enough people like it must feel
good to you know uh why do we need we
don't need the mlm that you don't need a
down line if you're a celestial
and we need to sell them on uh
yeah you're moving up the pyramid or
you're celestial already um
my other question is if a celestial can
make something as intricate as the
eternals like robots that don't know
their robots that have all this
artificial intelligence and super powers
and they look like gemma chan and you
know like everything uh how could they
they can't just make us they can't just
make like a star or like up like another
celestial like those seem easier like
just like how hard is it to make any of
this i don't understand why they would
need a whole planet to make a new
celestial yeah and their whole like uh
non-interference thing if it really is
to just increase the population just
have have druid you know create a
planet-wide orgy nine months later you
know you're you're you're in egg town
town baby
it just seems like a really ineffective
system where you gotta wait you gotta
wait like millennia and you gotta like
incubate them inside these plants you
gotta kill billions of views like so
much bother every time turtles too
should be them hiring a uh outside
celestial management consultant
like like the mitt romney of celestials
like bain capital comes into play supply
yeah i also i don't understand why we
need more celestials like i don't know
like
are you do
is this like adoption like i don't
understand
yeah where did the first celestial come
from also you're a real chicken egg
problem on the uh the back of a turtle
on top of another spot
uh all right let's let's keep watching
hi
there's theena a warrior who freaks out
when she remembers she's angelina jolie
and shouldn't be sharing screen time
with these nobodies yoga mash who's
never met a problem he couldn't fist
fastos who does all his science by way
of naruto hand signs druid he sucks
druix sucks ajax keeper of the sacred
iphone gold orb edition that lets her
call daddy aj makari who should have
been called fastos because holy crap how
are we supposed to keep all these
characters straight sprite a pixie with
the power of being small and having a
knife
yeah pause the
power distribution
all over the place with the eternals
i feel like to make it it's kind of
justice league but exaggerated where you
have the one
person who can kill the deviants with
his laser eyes and flight and super
strength he got like five powers i think
that's a full superman yeah you get the
full superman and the rest of them are
like
you are a great storyteller
gilgamesh really it's like i can i got
like like a goal like he's i'm the iron
fist like that doesn't the rest of these
are like god powers and he's like you
can punch hard you can punch hard
peanuts because she just has like those
blades like she's just
lady
she's just lady um but she's got
she's got she's mad weary you know she's
got
that what is that a thing mad weary yeah
that is that's like i looked it up
that's from the comics that's it and
it's not it's gonna just drop on us like
that i assumed it was like
m-a-d-w-e-a-r-y like they're mad weary
yo but no it's not it's like a whole
crazy like magic spelling fantasy
spelling like maduiri the medullary yeah
it's like uh it's like
it looks talking in the comics yeah yeah
they were they just threw a lot at us in
this film and you know maybe maybe they
spaced it out in like episodes or part
one part two or it's it's like an
opposite avengers where they each one
got their own film and then they
reunited them so it's all a big deal but
when you're throwing out mad weary
celestial deviants
all these things happening at once i
don't know i i kind of like that it's
it's you know it's like it's crazy and
trippy and weird it does feel like a
jack kirby comic in that way
yeah could he used about five less
eternals
five less than turtles and one more
edible for me i think that would have
probably gotten me through it feels like
it just sometimes feels like i i don't
know if it's the case because a lot of
people were like oh it should have been
like a mini series or we get more time
with all the eternal it does feel like
some of their stories just we don't get
enough
of them like like they set up you know
kingo as this bollywood star but we see
like a third of one day like there's
almost no
using it in the movie and and like that
that's the kind of stuff that i feel
like it just makes me want to see more
but i get it as as kind of a knock of
this movie it does feel like
some of our some of our understanding of
who these characters are is a little
incomplete yeah
uh all right say it for eternals too
let's keep watching
i'm sorry cersei king go a bollywood
star who makes you wonder if all the
time camille spent getting jacked should
have gone to dance lessons instead
okay would pause we got to talk about
kinko
i mean poor camille because not poor
camille i mean look at him he's doing
great
but right um
so he you know by his own accord like
he's like i'm gonna get jacked for this
film like no one right the interview no
one asked him to get super jacked like
most of the all the eternals like
they don't look like they're the most in
shape crew um they don't all look like
you know like they all took the
super soldier serum so he didn't have to
do that for this role but she like but
khloe zhao apparently like tricked him
into saying that he was gonna have a big
action scene she's like i've changed it
to a big dance scene
i wanted a big dancing it sort of feels
like they they don't fully go for it i
couldn't tell if it was like camille
just didn't want to learn all of the
dancers he's doing a lot of like chest
up stuff he's got the the shoulders and
the facial expressions he's nailing
the
the bodily transformation and then what
we ended up seeing which was like the
waist up dancing i it does seem like she
was like okay like we're going to
introduce you in a big bollywood action
scene and then they introduce them in a
kind of tepid bollywood dance number
[ __ ] out the climax
[Music]
like you come with me we're not involved
in this part yeah we're not doing this
it's third x stuff we don't worry about
it it's the skadood's crew
that's that's the that's the marvel
movie i want to see i just want to see a
bunch of people who are like i'm p snap
this isn't for me let me know when you
finish it yeah it's like it's it's luis
from the uh from the ant-man films it's
one
yeah
um and kingo yeah you can go yeah i
don't chat just like listen you got you
let us know how it goes you deal with it
yeah i just
i feel like i would be
like my shirt would be off
in every scene if i if i looked like
that or if i trained that hard to be in
this movie and then like had to just
stay
clothed i would be pissed
i don't know what happened there the
eternals do wear the most clothes of
like all of the marvel they they're all
wearing they're dressed like power
rangers yeah but they wear the most
ridiculous
all right uh they're the only ones that
don't have to rely on like tony stark
inventing them something new they just
stand up against the wall and it appears
so yeah convenience is a lot higher than
other marvels yes yep
all right keep going icarus who's like
superman if he had to be convinced that
human life had any value so like you
know zack snyder superman
[Music]
and cersei whose warm dignified
performance is impossible to focus on
because someone thought it wouldn't be
distracting to paris cersei with two of
the leads from game of thrones you are
very beautiful cersei i love you cersei
no you love daenerys or maybe margery
tyrell i'm still hashing out my erotic
fanfic i don't want it
i never have oh yes you do no kiss
i mean i thought cersei was good uh she
was a good character but
that took me out of it every single time
uh one of those two dudes was like
cersei i love you cersei it's like
that's not like an easter egg that's
like an omelette you know a denver
omelet in your face
i ever saw game of thrones that was that
was insane it's it's like having like a
like a character like named mickey
choosing between like donald and pluto
like it's just incredibly distracting to
and very hot
it just made me feel like you know what
every eternal should have just been a
game of thrones character like why or
why are we even messing around at this
point just like sprite arya stark now
just like phil fill the roster yeah
that that seemed like a wild choice to
make like how could you
do they think that that was just like a
winking nod
like this i mean i i honestly doubt it
was purposeful at all it's cersei's from
the comics that
they wanted these guys like br how many
british actors of the age-appropriate
range like half of them were probably in
game of thrones that they considered for
those roles i don't know the game of
thrones or doctor strange and yeah we
only make five movies a year so
eventually this is gonna keep happening
you know yeah it's like we we're you
know we're there's also doctor who what
one of those guys could have easily been
a doctor what companion or whatever yeah
all right keep going
for a movie that's all about tracking
down characters you just met a few
minutes ago we need to find the others
we need to go find the others we have to
bring everyone back together and since
no one thought to set up a group text
take a whirlwind tour of all their solo
projects whether they're just chilling
on a marvel issued retirement farm wanda
visioning before it was cool druid sucks
he does nuking japan i did this or they
just got left back on the spaceship like
a baby in a hot car but once these
neutral avengers have reassembled
they'll discover their secret mission to
literally the world as they learn their
true purpose was to fertilize earth with
enough man batter to hatch a celestial
sorry for phrasing it that way i'm just
unsatisfied after marvel's first sex
scene i.e three dimly lit pumps in the
missionary position can you believe
that's all
look what kingo did i mean i'm i'm
respect to them for actually pumping you
know on screen pumps there are three
actual on-screen pumps
i was pretty shocked by that um
i don't know thought overall thoughts
and feelings did it feel uh i mean is it
ever necessary but did it feel uh earned
or or enjoyable or you know i think it
was pretty like i'll start i think it
was kind of uh uh
cold and like dispassionate and not hot
but i think that that in retrospect is
like uh
it's like a portent of their of their
relationship that actually they aren't
on the same page and they do have this
disconnect between the two of them but
they aren't like going at each other
like crazy that they actually are on
kind of different sides of this moral
equation so maybe it was a purposefully
bland sex scene that they that they
aren't like simpatico like that they
have negative chemistry like every time
i'm sorry cersei and icarus i know it's
supposed to be like this epic love story
and every time it's just like
it feels like someone took two like
action figures and just started pressed
them together you know like it
definitely felt like okay well i'm gonna
take these two barbies and now they're
gonna make out but like it didn't
i never felt like oh yeah this is a love
for the ages it was always like oh i
guess you guys used to bang or whatever
but
yeah i agree they kind of undercut their
relationship by showing her first with
dane whitman and and so we're on that
we're on their side like we're rooting
for dana and cersei to get back together
and so when we're introduced to
you know rob stark it's like wait who's
this guy so i think that kind of messes
up the i agree they don't have a ton of
chemistry on screen either but i did
like the scene just because i thought
that there was a lot of this movie that
it really did try to feel aesthetically
and tonally
different from the other marvel movies
that really did like that whole sequence
feels nothing like anything you've seen
in a marvel movie before it really sets
this apart and makes us feel different
and like its own thing and i i enjoyed
it on that level for sure yeah
there's also there were other
there were some other romances that kind
of caught me off guard or like was it a
romance like with makari and druid like
what's going on like that was more like
a crush like i don't think that was like
a romance but it was like they you know
they've got a little sweaty you know you
have your you know uh when you're
younger you have like your work flirt
you know when you're like young and
single like you've got the person that
you flirt with at work but like
it's going to come up
husband and wife but not outside yeah
yeah and then we can we can circle back
to uh uh sprite and her and that love
triangle between her and uh
and icarus icarus and uh
but it's like
you know obviously they're not going to
depict anything like that on screen but
isn't it also messed up that eternals
are dating people 3 000 years younger
than them
it's the you know it's the old ass
vampire problem i've talked about this
where it's like
i wonder
because it's always the dude vampires
that like date like these high school
girls and you know the lady vampires are
just like
well there he goes again dating another
15 year old you know so i would imagine
that yeah if you're an eternal um i
guess at a certain point you just have
to be like look like there's nothing
else for us to do and we got to get our
three pumps in
someone
but uh
yeah
it doesn't bother me when it's like you
know dane whitman's a grown man i don't
i don't think it's you know it's like a
40 year old dating a 55 year old but you
got to figure that there's levels to
groan when you're when you reach year 1
000 that like honestly i bet after like
year 50 it's like i've seen it i guess
how much more is there to get
um but i will i will say the sprite
thing at the end
very weird like she's gonna go to what
junior high and get to know children
like no no no no no adults only you guys
like take a few years age up to being an
adult and now you can
she doesn't need to go to school she's
going to lie for seven dollars also she
can shape-shift she can do everything
up until like the physical up until the
three pumps she can turn into any she's
3000 years old can take the form of
anyone setting her to middle school was
like what what you gonna learn history
she was there what did she need to learn
she's gonna be the annoying kid in class
who corrects the the professor yeah like
but now we're gonna read jane austen oh
well i know jane
there's nothing left for her to learn
yeah that was me that was my magically
ager up to like 19 and send her on her
way yeah
all right let's keep going can you
believe that's all we get look what
kingo did for this film and you don't
even pop his shirt off you gotta reward
that effort eternals two the search for
king goes dingo let's make it happen
so if your idea of fun is watching ten
people debate the trolley problem for
two and a half hours where the closest
thing to a relatable character is an
immortal movie star's human pet he's
worked with me for 50 years fly don't
walk to your nearest couch for the film
that puts the universe in mcu that
despite the reviews is far from the
worst in the franchise are you well eric
i can't get too excited
tony how do you go to the bathroom
so pause just like that why do we think
that this was the most poorly reviewed
marvel movie because i i stand by that
this was like
not definitely not the worst it's in the
lower half for me but by no means is it
the absolute worst marvel movie release
but why do we think that it got the
critical reception that it did
i do think part of it is is um
like one said like because it is so
different and people go in with a
certain expectation like marvel movies
are roller coasters like their rides and
like that's a lot of what you go into it
looking for and this wasn't like you
know it this isn't equip fest it is
thinky it is very very talky um
and so i think that that's part of it
and i do think we got to take uh the
lockdown of it all because wasn't this
like uh the first one where it was this
one of shangchi was the first one where
it was like you have to see this in
theaters like we're not doing this the
the duels believe that
you're not yeah
was the first one where you had to go to
theaters and then it was like a month
later on
i think i imagine that would have
improved
the experience though seeing this in
theaters definitely yeah yeah but i just
don't think a lot of people
did that
um this was not necessarily one where
because like with shanghi
you know it's like this new character
and this new world and obviously like
any time that you make something for
people of color we're like yes thank you
we will go do this so that you will
continue doing this for us and luckily
shangti also wound up being really
really really good um and i think with
this i just don't think you know i i
mean it's marvel it did fine people were
going but this wasn't like a spider-man
where it was like you have to be there
day one you know
yeah i mean i think that there's
obviously
when you see a marvel movie these days
there's a certain set uh expectation
that you have for the tone at least that
i think this deviated from
um
but i think that it's also just like
you know you're on top for a little too
long and people are just like looking
for an excuse to kind of to kind of
bring you down um
and also like people genuinely do get
tired of things after a while and uh
when they don't do as good a job of
giving you that thing again it's it's a
perfect opportunity to unleash all the
frustrations you've had about these
movies in the past uh on this one um
it's a it's a big swing this movie i
think it's not gonna work for everybody
it's a it's a big departure from what
they've done and i think that that makes
it a lightning rod for criticism and
attention and i think that the fact that
it's a director who's coming off of an
oscar-winning
breakthrough film puts a lot of extra
sort of attention on it that maybe some
other movies from less notable
international filmmakers wouldn't so i
felt like yeah this had a different kind
of
focus than you know other like a black
widow or something and uh and i think
that brought a little bit of extra
scrutiny and probably the knives out a
little bit i also think among fans we
know that and i don't mean this in a
pejorative like in a negative way like
they'll take it that way but we know
that fans love you know references and
stuff that plays very heavily into being
a marvel movie and part of this ongoing
world and i mean obviously we saw it
with spider-man that's what so much of
the hype about doctor strange is people
love when they find interesting ways to
like fold these stories together and
this one is almost purposefully other
than the post-credit sequences kind of
taking itself out of that equation and
like what if we were on this totally
different scale from all these other
stories and it wouldn't even make sense
to reference like the ground level stuff
that's happening when you're talking
about you know thousand-year-old gods or
whatever so i thought that that
obviously blunts the impact on some
level too that there aren't a million
little fun connections to every other
marble
do you think it would have been helped
if you know when rsm appears over the
horizon that you just see hawkeye like
notching an arrow and like aiming it at
him just in case
i mean i think yes i think stuff like
that little little easter eggs and stuff
probably would have for a lot of fans
made this more enjoyable get arsham one
of those blank caps so that he can just
like be in the universe and no one
really is
get him that like blanks yeah the
unbranded uh black baseball cap just the
eternals in ancient egypt fighting oscar
isaac as apocalypse come on oh there you
go i want him to step out of the
multiverse just you know go learning
ugly blue suit that he can't stand to
wear physically oh if that's somehow it
uh one of his uh one of moon knight's
personalities that will just totally uh
recontextualize x-men apocalypse uh okay
let's let's finish watching they just
tried to do something a little different
this time but don't worry marvel will
never make that mistake again phew
starring
cersei roman
stark kent this wasn't in the script
angelina jolie generally doesn't know
how a toaster works selma dayak the
fling in the north the big dick silicon
valet
sprite ginger zero sugar
shaper boy
dev schlepper
druid sucks bury me with my golden arm
clifford the big red god
gotta catch em all ropeymon
all right you're in this movie too
patton oh yeah that thing and harry
styles
eternal run time of the plotless grind
very good
why is bright going to school she's
thousands of years old not trying to
meet kids her own age what's she going
to learn in seventh grade okay maybe
spanish somos amigos
de la universidad
you probably invented
there's no spanish
come on
spend another 500 years in mesoamerica
please
yeah we have dual lingo now like you can
yeah
maybe that's what she was doing on her
cell phone at the very end oh man um all
right we had some uh some other stuff
that i want to bring up but i think we
did some believed scenes about them so
let's watch those real quick
fastos who does all his science by way
of minority report hand gestures druid
barry keoghan's latest twisted little
cree who forces humans to do his bidding
i just wanted to put that clip in him in
an entrepreneur
makari who in true speech to fashion
could end the movie in 30 seconds so
they just keep her hidden until the
third act sprite who's become jaded by
the declining quantity and quality of
pedophiles over the course of human
history now i want to know what it feels
like to grow up to fall in love
story
gemma and the holograms dance dance
revolutionary
vision board the boy who flew too close
to the sun like way too close
theme titans maleficents and sensibility
mad weary of this movie
mad i weary
getting hayek af
from husk till dawn ajak of the show
broke jack mountain black knight's watch
k-i-n-g-o and kingo was his name-o
inhuman growth hormone once upon a time
in bollywood
young adult not a girl not yet a human
the fast and the curious
speed spacer flash of the titans the man
with the golden guns
judge red and pop star fox never stop
planet hopping
the just us league
the gods must be lazy
apocalypse vow
so
the thing that uh didn't make it in that
i realized far too late is that the
eternals
sync up almost perfectly with the
characters from
the film in kento
and uh it probably would have gotten
flagged if we had done the parody song
we'd have to like tweak the notes a
bunch yeah but yeah it doesn't sound
exactly the same yeah
uh
but yeah i'm gonna assembly madrigal
aaron i i wrote a whole family madrigal
parody that you know i don't feel like
singing right now i thought i was gonna
sing it but i'm actually not going to
i'll post it i'll post it somewhere but
it does we discovered that that not only
does that match up but also the ninja
turtles also have
counterparts well we were debating well
fastos obviously does machines
cersei leads cersei leads and fastos
does machines yeah and then and then we
we were very kingo's the party dude
kingo is a party and it's
called the cruisers
cool but i think it's ruined
you were saying
cool but rude yeah um and ajax is
splinter uh some hayek is splinter yeah
i think it's something splinter
i can i can picture her being like i
made a funny and then laughing at
herself yeah that feels like somehow
wow i forgot how many druid sucks jokes
we got in mexico
is a um
sprite or
makari casey jones no well i think uh
dane whitman would be casey jones oh
yeah yeah definitely definitely
oh and uh the cameraman uh
oh that's it
[Laughter]
is it but is a is fastest then do we do
we need to open up some more room is he
baxter
no he's he's donatello okay fine yeah
yeah yeah and who's our hashem is he
crang
yeah okay i think so all right
right
uh all right uh well that was fun um
let's let's go
i can do this all day
let's go
oh blade is shredder probably wait it's
definitely sure
uh let's see um jeffy elvish and asked
should they have tried to introduce the
characters over several movies or series
before doing a team up i don't think
they were going to give them the rope
the runway for that to
it was all or nothing i think they
couldn't
best case scenario if this does if this
did huge if this did no way home numbers
yeah you could splinter off and do i
mean obviously they're thinking about
dane whitman black knight stuff but you
could maybe come up with a
you know like what could we could we put
cersei in something else or could we do
something else with druig or whatever
but um i think that they make enough
changes from the comics that i don't
think anyone would have been mad if they
have the eternals if this was about
five or six eternals instead of two well
you could always and then you add more
in sequels anyway i mean they're at the
end of this movie is they're going to go
out to space and look for more eternals
anyway
i i would have i i think that i would
have snapped half the eternals and
that's that's probably my one big fix in
this movie gets a lot better um
let's see uh
james bond asked what other obscure jack
kirby creation do you want to spend 200
million dollars on is it devil dinosaur
yes
yes it is
well they were gonna do new gods and
then
no no gods now right oh it's a cat um
yeah they were gonna do new gods and
then like no
yeah i mean he needed commandy for a
while which would be really cool which
is like it's a post-apocalyptic future
but there's like manimals it's populated
by like intelligent sentient animals who
like walk around
and command he is like a cave boy in the
future that would be yeah
cool i i would i would be into that no
three pumps in that movie
you are very disturbing
um i want to see uh i know it's not jack
kirby but i want to see mojo and the
mojo verse um
yes yes yeah
we got a little tease in deadpool too
but almost treated as a gag yeah spirals
gonna look so cool yeah
um all right what's up babies x-men
babies yeah it'll happen on a long
enough timeline it'll all happen um
let's see uh adam halpernass are you
more excited for uh chloe zhao's dracula
western or uh a follow-up to the
eternals would you like to see her next
or do you want to see her go back to uh
making the prestige oscar films or a
dracula western or eternity i think that
that dracula western sounds pretty cool
yeah i'm definitely into i'm unfamiliar
with this uh could you tell me more
i mean i think that's most of what we
know
i mean i'll see if there's any other
details i could find but pretty high
concept i think that that's about
yeah
uh it's a yeah she's saying a sci-fi
western uh based on the most famous
vampire of all dracula
um but i don't we don't have an original
futuristic sci-fi western with the
themes of being on society's fringes um
dracula is often on the fringe or
something that's all we've got so far so
sort of like a nomad land but if
uh
she was dracula
um okay let's see oh we didn't talk
about fastos being there for the atomic
bombs i think arthur mingo had a
question about that uh but i think that
just uh
what do you think about that moment
that's so weird he's so weird what a
what a weird choice for him to be like i
did this and it's like yeah
that's happened well
yeah inspiring human
you know technological evolution it's
always weird when these big tentpole
hollywood studio popcorn movies try to
do that like integrate real
dark moments in history like the harry
potter series or the fantastic beast
series doing it as well where
grindelwald suddenly like
but world war ii we could prevent it
it's like i don't know if i need it
yeah
it doesn't it doesn't work the way they
wanted to investing their world in
reality it just feels like kind of
it's yeah just to stick to
i don't know it reminds me of or not
reminds me of but it's like
because people are old enough to have
lived through uh the bombing of
hiroshima and nagasaki like when i'm in
my 80s or 90s
and i go see a marvel movie and fast
dose is there in like 9 11. like what if
i done
it's just not gonna we're not that far i
j i'm not going to spoil the end again i
just watched a tv series that ends with
a reveal that a character has gone back
in time by using the the world trade
center and it's like was it mark
wahlberg that's also a little weird no
no they see that
they're still standing it's like i'm not
in the i'm not in my own universe it's
like oh it's weird
anyways yeah fringe did that as well
fringe also did it like it's an
alternate reality look the towers are
still standing it's like uh you could
come right away
um well
that's we don't have those
gotta experiment until you find the line
but i i found that uh fast dose in the
smoking ruins
when there's probably like still people
dying there and they see fastos be like
in a boat dressed like bill nye the
science guy going what have i done like
it's just like go 100 years earlier you
know like like said it in a time where
none of us none of us ever knew anybody
who was alive for that horrible thing
again i think if this was all taking
place in like babylonian myth times and
and then like up through athens and then
like maybe the middle ages it was just
like him looking out over like the
battle of antietam or something like
that
five five that's fine i never should
have invented the trebuchet right yes
what was i thinking
all right uh good times this is more fun
than the eternals i'd i'd wait
but uh we'll be back um i gave you a
clue already up front uh that it was
grunty and uh yeah i'd say we this next
one doubles down on that so
we'll be back next week for more
australian commentaries thanks for
watching thanks for joining us bye
[Music]
foreign